ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week where my life has
felt normal that was when you found out
peter
that spell that you botched it started
pulling in visitors from every universe
what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop him
spider-man no way home when you're
thinking hey i'm about to do something
that could break the universe run it by
us next time in theaters december 17th
this is peter leave a message yeah peter
this is happy
who are those guys huh
whether the guys made a mud what's going
on call me back
when i shut that spell down we started
getting some visitors from every
universe
multiverse is real
was that a dinosaur
in theaters december 17th